le marché de l'intérim a été frappée en
quelques jours en raison de la crise
sanitaire et du confinement
c'est le cas de lagence option en terme
situées à montigny le bretonneux le
marché d'un game vient de vivre une
chute assez catastrophique atteignant
une baisse varie entre moins 60 - 70 %
en fait de la scène tout à la situation
il faut savoir que ce choc-là c'est ça
représente 5 à 4 à 5 fois plus que le
choc de 2008
pendant cette période les secteurs du
bâtiment et de l'industrie ont été les
plus impactés plus de 60 % de perte
d'activité pour le btp et environ 50 %
pour l'industrie le 11 mai lagence
option un terme a rouvert les
intérimaires étaient nombreux à revenir
mais paraît de poser la question à
savoir si si vous aviez des besoins de
la semaine prochaine on a pensé que le
secteur du nettoyage
allez avoir un rebond on a pu constater
que c'était pas le cas aujourd'hui il
n'ya pas de secteur à notre niveau
kiki qui est plus avantagés par rapport
à un autre
cette crise a donc touché tous les
secteurs et engendré une perte
importante pour le fondateur de cette
société créée il ya douze ans père de
trésorerie on est on je pense à plus de
cinq cent mille euros de deux paires de
trésorerie sur sûr c'est sur ces 3 -
effectivement de non activité
donc on est encore très loin
effectivement de nos nos chiffres de
début d'année parce qu'on avait réalisé
de vraiment un début d'année qui était
exceptionnel ce qu'on était plus de 40 %
de déchets d'affaires par rapport à et
de -1
on espère effectivement retrouvé sept
cette croissance du site d'ici la fin de
l'année quand certains de leurs clients
n'ont pas encore repris à 100 % leurs
activités comme dans le secteur de
l'industrie ou du bâtiment